hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einer
weiteren folge microsoft games zusammen
mit kamera de hallo hallo hin und wieder
in der letzten folge die ihr höchst
wahrscheinlich bekomme gesehen haben
sollte tun machen
ich schieße war kurz ab da oben vielen
dank
da haben wir auch schon jetzt schon
weiter geschafft und zwar sind wir jetzt
schon hier bei dieser mario map und blog
ich muss daran teil und wir sind relativ
weit kommen
also ich denke wir sachen locker schon
80 prozent der karte haben wir locker
durch oder dafür aber wirklich ein blog
nämlich nicht von game 5 sondern halt
bei den wahlhelfern von der mario kart
hier
wie gesagt geben falls besteht aus von
verschiedenen spielen wir sind jetzt
schon bei mario angekommen und ja wir
die kacke war halt immer bekommen hat
letzte folge schon gut zusammengefasst
einer springt vor und fällt runter der
andere macht sie ihm irgendwie intuitiv
nach und springt auch unter gutes
beispiel gott ich sagen wir steigen
jetzt mal anlauf mit einander her direkt
fünf einander beim ersten stein
heruntergefallen war nicht so toll sehr
gehalten etwa peter solar und herunter
zu fallen
aber da fehlte wirklich sonnen sondern
holz hinten gemacht gerade also daran
liegt nicht mehr habe ich eben gerade
von einer sekunde gemacht und alle
aktiven hat mal auf dem set gelesen so
ein motto machen statt auf das ist ja
dass das spiel modus und mir geändert
wurde
okay gut ich versuche jetzt wieder
diesen einen komischen job den du auch
vorhin mainz zu den hier trinkt einen
schluck hier ein schulgebäude das dorf
ihr nas trophy der plan sieht auf jeden
fall heute aus dass wir durch wert
mitmachen würde ich sagen
wie kommen ja immer ein stück weiter
weiße irgendwie immer deine aufnahmen
das schaffen wir es ja immer mit den
abschnitten
mir ist manchmal noch so sage ich mal in
den verschiedenen karten so eine art
brücken folge hat man bei mir immer und
bei dir kommen wir dann immer weiter
heute bin ich super gesprungen am anfang
muss ich sagen wo bist du eigentlich
ich bin wieder ganz am anfang ganz am
anfang nicht ganz ganz auf anfang seien
nur ganz am anfang oktober bin ich
runter ich wünsche vorlagen in diesen
spielen wir sie da drin gucken
nein ich bin ich komm ich finden
ich bin gleich auf dem auf dem auf dem
programm und wird ja auch teilweise
geschrieben
wir sollen nicht so viel trollen uns
nicht so viel abschließend aber dass
erben das ist eine regel dann regeln
müssen beachtet werden
richtig leute hier das mag ich auch
gerade an der karte und ich wünsche mir
weiterhin c't du nur weil du nicht du
wirst mich über jeden spielt kann sich
langsam genug geht oder brauchst
übersieht eine ewigkeit gesund um willst
du ihn gab es folgende wir beide waren
richtig gut in deiner folge guck mal wie
ich wir beide waren richtig gut nur ich
nicht nein herr doch das ging eigentlich
sogar voll ich hab sogar holzkohle liga
zwei bekommen mann und jetzt ist ja
einfach so eine scheiße dass wir bei den
leitern sprühen ich versuche jetzt
einfach dass ihr das ich euch diese
blöden spinnen spinnenweben daher sparen
mache jetzt einfach das immer so
der blog ist zu weit weg glaube ich oder
du hast es geschafft mit den rekord wenn
ich gut
du hast es geschafft mit den zeitsprung
und schmecken lage doch das ist kein
problem es schafft man von da unten ich
habe ich hab's gleich geschafft und
wieder habe ich kohle zwei stücke kohle
noch mal zwei stücke aus
wieso klappt ich das endlich wieder
klappt das nicht wie sowieso schaffe ich
das nicht dann kann ein sagenhafter
heißt das kann nicht wahr sein glauben
ich bin nicht traurig gerade ich habe es
ja gar nicht geschafft für uns beide ist
ernsthaft bis wirklich schon so gut weiß
jetzt vorne die stars gleich durch durch
mit der map machen
oh gott jetzt ein mega weiter sprung und
hier noch kohle holen
ich schaffe den ersten sprung nicht ein
sprung vom ende
oder willst es war letztlich punkt ich
bin einfach durchgerutscht und bin dann
gestorben
ich war ein vor dem bett runtergefallen
hannover idee komme ich sage ich hallo
nimmt sie fackeln hallo nah an dem wir
die abkürzung gleicht nun doch auch
ledige abkürzung nicht mehr sehen es die
abkürzung spiel noch mal vor was wird
ich habe nichts gemacht ja wirklich
nichts gemacht das kann man bei mir
sehen ich hab nicht geschlagen oder so
komme ich mal eben ganz schnell
ob du bist tot
ok jetzt hat mir mal wie das geht weiß
ich fall immer aus der welt hab ich
gesehen ein neues shampoo heute
benutzten sri fall gut findet jetzt ja
das bringt wenn du dich im fallen zum
airport erst dann kriegt trotzdem den
fall schade aber ich habe das gefühl ich
hoffe dass jetzt das richtig gut daran
gerade das habt ihr genau gesehen der
aufnahme hat auf einmal so gelegt bei
mir das habt ihr alle gesehen in der
aufnahme ist hat mal so gelegt das war
unglaublich
wie kommt der grund ruft hallo wo es
dass ich gar nicht sein
warum uns einfach einen checkpoint
daneben setzen dass wir diese ganze
abspringen oder formen
ich liebe dich komme super toller
ziemlich klasse ich stark und ohne
witzig war er ein blog vor dem ende
das ist deprimierend was wir davor ja
ich war einfach per vor konnte das
schild praktisch lesen
es war nicht mehr viel wenn es wirklich
brennt ja die ganzen verein
okay ich habe zwei diese blöcke
ich werde jetzt einfach irgendwo
hinsetzen wo wir denken dass wir da
nicht lang kommen dass er sandra nicht
leiden
das brauchen wir doch gar nicht nee ich
bin ja gleich wieder am ende gleich in
fünf minuten
ich mache jetzt wieder mit diesen mit
diesen spinnenweben mal hier sagt komm
leute jetzt wenn ich das jetzt schaffe
dann mache ich irgendwas jetzt in diesem
land schaffe dann film ich ab jetzt
meinen kompletten tag und auch wenn ich
das schaffe
wenn ich das mit diesem sprung geschafft
dann werdet ihr ab jetzt meinen
kompletten tag verfilmt sehen also dann
fühle mich einfach alles was ich noch
machen und das dann irgendwie auf zeit
gar an ohren also das ist jetzt mal so
ich werde viel schaffen
ich werde es nicht schaffen wenn du
schaffst du nicht nein ach so ich bin
jetzt auf diesem schalter
es soll nicht sein er soll ich sein kann
als es kann doch nicht sein komme weiß
über dir ich schaffe es immer als als
süß gemacht hast
da haben wir sogar wenn ihr bei komme
die letzte folge anschaut da waren wir
beide dann nebeneinander die teilweise
und weit nach diesem scheiß leiter
sprung nach diesen sprung und jetzt
schafft den käufer nicht
ich krieg die krise hier ja gar nix mehr
hin
das ist das ist ja ich kann ich könnte
heulen mensch man mensch meier ich weiß
auch nicht mehr was ich dazu sagen soll
hier ganz ehrlich ich habe auch gerade
so eine phase hier die komplette
motivation gerade an dieser mario apple
verloren
es geht einfach nicht hinkriege wenn die
nächste map auch noch hart ist hätten
sie lieber game harten ingolstadt
irgendwie game 2 5
guter witz oder www f5 hat oder keine
ahnung hat hart hart weiß nicht just
heard level des fonds keine ahnung das
einfach so krass kommen unterstütze ich
mal hier ich beobachte dich komm let's
go ok ponys und vormarsch
momentan liegt
dr
ich gehöre zum ende und schaue mal ob
ich dort gehen auch mal gucken wie weit
es noch ist ich zeig euch mal wo ich
vorhin gestorben bin hier sind ja diese
scheiss seiner sprüche ja und man als
mensch gestorben das ist so peinlich
hier seien alle die das ist alles easy
das ist easy easy hatte hier bin ich
gestorben da bin ich gespannt bei dieser
einleiter da konnte ich nicht raus
stellen weil sie guckt guck mal ich war
hier dass ich komme sogar noch in form
seiner folge zu mir teleportiert mit
akon ich drauf springen irgendwie so
league muss man einfach nur lang laufen
da muss man auch nur überlaufen das
relativ easy da auch das ja alles
abgesichert dass auch an kuchen
der rest ist ja gar nicht mal so schwer
dass er als irgendwie abgesichert weiße
jaja wurde anfang der schwierig
okay ich schaffe das jetzt ich komme zu
dir
ich hoffe dass jetzt kannst ja mal von
der seite beobachten die motivation
geben
ok ich fahre jetzt einfach kommen bei
anderen stadt hier irgendwie wo bist du
auch da hinten cool du hast in den
linken den sprung schafft der es geht
jetzt eigentlich sogar ab jetzt wird
erst mal relativ einfach wieder dass ein
spender dann wird man mit derlei jetzt
ist es so richtiges mario fillinger von
der seite zweimal zu kennen diese sicht
hier mal einfach ich spiele jetzt
einfach mal nur und dokumentiert nein
kommt nicht finden je einmal beobachtest
du mich noch mario sound so
ich kann einfach nicht mehr
das ist doch das ist doch schreibt meine
kommentare ob ich nehme jetzt einfach
diese zweite glocke die ich habe und
setze jetzt irgendwo hin so als kleine
hilfe so hart eine kleine hilfe kleine
hilfe am rande nur hinsetzen 30 da wo du
über runter willst also dass von hier
auf diesem scheiss auf dem us-blog dahin
richtig ob ich das schaffe schaffe
wieder nein du schaffst es ja nicht ich
lasse mir die zeit jetzt nutzen die
blöcke dass ich wenigstens bei diesem
sprung jetzt hinweg komme das erlaube
ich mir jetzt mal eben weil ihr wollt ja
auch nicht dass wir zehn millionenfach
der gleiche film so wird es auch ein weg
das sieht nicht so karg außerdem
spinnweben teil dann ist
scheibe anfänger hilfe der sommer kommt
er denn kommt jetzt dahin recht sagen
häufig hier lang so zack zack zack zack
da bist du gerade weggeflogen habe ich
gerade gesehen ich wollte nicht den
sprung hingucken
das ist es geht ja nicht die sonne so
nicht auf aber die sache wird immer
heller und jetzt will ich total hier
wieder an der face kam auch machen aber
jetzt sollte ich eigentlich schaffen
leute die um kim
william d
ja ich hab mir gerade richtig hab mir
noch mal diesen baum sprung gerade eben
im creative nur angeguckt er hätte aus
christlicher sprung aber er ist machbar
ich habe ihn auch schon mehrmals
geschafft
das sprinten auf man mag nicht mehr
scheiße doch ich will das schaffen
deswegen werde ich voll rein
ich will die will das schaffen ich war
schon wieder voll wald und jetzt reißt
ich möchte das auch schaffen jetzt
wundert sich noch richtig zu selbst so
den ehrgeiz
also ich finde man lernt aber auch durch
die carl ist und wenig spring also ich
verbessere mich hier durch ein wenig
ständig ach wo kommen denn die brocade
irritiert mich voll ja doch normalität
er seine hilfe
dum dum dum davon spielen crafter es
wird trainiert gerade in super mario
rotter also irgendwie ich weiß noch
durchhalten ich hab nichts bilder
angeguckt gerade so auch die karte hier
die fand ich voll vom baustil richtig
episch dachte mir urteil ja ich habe es
gerade glaube ich glaubst du wer
unterwegs ja ein klasse alles relativ
alt aber ab hier habe ich ein interesse
hat man wenn du dir ich habe mich mal
teleport
aber ich hab den sprüngen den schaff's
nicht die ich kannte hier gemacht haben
über die bäume nein ändert kann ich sein
doch dem den sprung über die bäume habe
ich auch schon geschafft jetzt auch noch
egal das spiegelt und die dramatik
wieder in der dekade spielen jetzt
besser ist es halt doch einfach ein
bisschen pokémon ja okay ich war auch
wirklich das ist bekloppt ich beobachte
dich jetzt mal ich beende dass er das
kann ich sein leute die sich weise zehn
minuten normaler wo bist du gerade
ich bin im du bist gestorben screen also
ja gut dann kann ich dich auch nicht
respekt hätten na gut ich probiere noch
dann den worten hier gerade und entweder
klappt oder es klappt nicht früher auch
katharina sag ich mal eine
überbelichtung dings das ist echt
unglaublich ladet euch die map unter
bevor sagt wir sind scheiße das ist so
schwer bisschen heulen machten video wie
er das geschafft eng wie mit einem
durchlauf folge für folge bei gott bis
dahin würde ich euch sagen morgen
schaffen wir jetzt aber auch versprochen
100 prozent ich hoffe dass morgen
ach ja verdammt
wenn wir zum super springer
naja gut freunde sekunde sekunde ich bin
kein fall weit
das gucke ich mir daran dass cox jedoch
an das mache ich nur meine okay ich
mache einfach den endkampf so lange dass
man denkt ja dann schreibt er eine kippa
das nahm hoch tut euch gefallen hat die
kommen steht auch in der beschreibung
alle netzwerke stehen
beschreibung alter du machst es nicht
wenn du brennst nicht was das hör auf
hör auf
wenn du den schaff das ist der
schwierigste von allem was ist nicht das
schwierigste in meiner schwierigsten
sich dann wegen fall schaden konnte
nichts bringen da müsst ihr weiterhin
unter druck
die leiter herunter nein man kann auch
hierüber ja aber die leiter ist oft viel
besser
das könnte sogar schalter
nein ich hasse dich okay freunde und
dann schaffen wir es ja